[Music]
I can confirm all victims had apparent
fatal gunshot injuries additionally four
of the six were burned at the location
by the
suspects as far as the motives uh we are
confident that this appears to be a
dispute over marijuana which resulted in
the murders we are still conducting
follow-up investigation but we are
confident we have arrested all the
subject all the suspects in this case
they are currently in custody with no
bail pending a review of the case from
the sanino County District Attorney's
office just speaking to sanino County
now obviously anytime you have mass six
people um that are murdered I mean
that's shocking to your conscience let's
be o honest but I can tell you that
since we've been investigating illegal
marijuana grows a number of body dumps
and things have been related to this
across our County and to give you an
exact number I'm sorry I don't have that
but it isn't an anomaly the anomaly here
is the amount of people that were
murdered of course and and this is a
problem and this is a problem that's not
really being talked about I can
guarantee you we got the five right
people and we're going to make sure this
is a strong case and we're very closely
with the da to bring them to justice
thank you for your
time